the Iowa caucuses are now just three
days away and we're seeing new signs
Americans are confident in their economy
a new CBS poll out this morning says
seventy-five percent of Americans think
the US economy is in good shape that is
the highest number in nearly 20 years
but many families still face big
challenges this morning we're kicking
off our new series every state has a
story and we're doing it from Iowa the
series focuses on how issues talked
about on the campaign trail actually
affect people all around the country
this morning it's the high cost of child
care according to a recent study in Iowa
76 percent of children under the age of
six have all available parents working
outside of the home in other words
they're gonna need child care Nikole
Killion is in Des Moines talking to moms
Nicole good morning it sounds like some
families are facing truly staggering
costs here yeah absolutely Toni and
you're a parent I'm a parent and for a
lot of parents out there we all know
that child care can be expensive and
here in Iowa the average cost is about
ten thousand dollars a year but for
single parents with multiple children
some of them are finding they're
spending significantly more up to 70
percent or more on their child care
four-year-old Dominic Miranda is all
smiles at playtime and pickup time his
mom Zoey is finishing maternity leave
and when she returns to her custodial
job she'll have to pay not just for one
day care bill but to there's some times
that I feel like I have to rub Peter to
pay Paul it is really really hard when
it comes to paying rent paying utilities
paying my cell phone paying a car
Stephanie Jewell is also a single mom
she gets assistance from the state but
fears losing it again I had gotten a
dollar raise at work but with that
dollar raise I ended up not qualifying
for child care assistance at all and the
bill went up to $1,500 a month and just
I mean that was more than my mortgage
payment United Way's Deanne Cook says it
illustrates Iowa's childcare cliff in
2020
estimated a family of three would have
to make less than 30 $1500 to qualify
Iowa's program has one of the very
lowest entry points so people who really
don't have enough to make ends meet are
still not able to get on childcare
assistance the issue has galvanized
Iowa's legislature and the presidential
candidates it makes no sense for
childcare to cost two-thirds of
somebody's income we can cover childcare
for all of our children in the city of
Pella this manufacturing plant took an
innovative approach organizing an
on-site childcare facility that offers
workers a reduced rate Kate gues has a
four year old in the program and manages
the company's HR do you see this as the
wave of the future here in Iowa I hope
so I think that there is a lot of
creative ways to address the childcare
gaps that we have here in the state and
we have across the country gaps that Zoe
hopes will eventually close to say by
now earlier this month
Iowa's governor put forth several
childcare proposals as for the upcoming
presidential contest some of the moms I
spoke to say they do believe that
childcare should be an important issue
in the this election but at the same
time they also are not necessarily
thrilled with some of the candidates and
some of them told me Tony maybe not even
caucus next week wow yeah mom's looking
for some kind of solution
dad's rooting for one - they've all if
you've done the childcare shuffle where
you run home to relieve the sitter yeah
oh yeah it's a big one and then you pay
that bill at the end of the week Nicole
thank you very much